Package management.
Everyone's talking about it.
Here's how we do it in Dart.
Of course, package management
is nothing new.
Java has Maven.
RubyGems has Bundler.
Node.js has npm.
And now Dart has Pub, the
package manager for Dart apps.
Pub exists today.
You can use it to integrate
third-party libraries into
your Dart app.
You can find the Pub
scripts in the SDK.
And Pub will even
walk transitive
dependencies for you.
Using Pub is quite simple.
First, import your Dart
libraries with the package
colon prefix.
Second, link those package
names to git repositories
using the pubspec file.
Third, install those packages
with Pub Install.
Let's see this in action.
Here we have a simple
app that, of course,
prints kitten pics.
It uses three different
packages,
catpic, frame and widget.
Notice how the editor
doesn't know
anything about these packages.
We haven't installed them yet.
The first thing we do is
create a pubspec file.
This will link your package
names to their git
repositories, in this case,
three different packages to
three different git
repositories.
Once we have our pubspec file,
we go to the command line, and
we run Pub install.
This will go out, clone the
the git repositories, and
create a packages directory
right next to our application.
Now the editor knows
about the packages.
In fact, we can see here
there's four packages.
This is an example of Pub's
transitive dependencies.
For instance, the catpic package
itself has a pubspec.
Looking inside, we can see that
catpic depends on kittens.
Now that we have all of our
packages loaded up and our
editor happy, let's go ahead
and run the application.
Sure enough, your life
is complete.
You have kitten pics
in your app.
And you can see how the cat
pics, the widgets, and the
frames all pulled together
from different libraries
across the net into one Dart
app, thanks to Pub.
What you saw was just the
beginning of Pub.
Here's what we're
working on next.
First, we're creating a
pub.dartlang.org hosting site.
Here you can publish, discover,
search and install
third-party libraries
and packages.
We'll also support the
concept of .tar.gz
packages for snapshots.
We'll also integrate Pub
into the Dart Editor.
And it'd be really cool to see
if we can help you decide
which packages to make, if we
integrate with interesting
metrics like what's the
number of forks or
watchers for this package.
This is where your feedback
can really help.
Please join the mailing list
at misc@dartlang.org.
File feature requests and
bugs at dartbug.com.
And, of course, test your
libraries and apps with Pub.
You just saw Pub, the package
manager for Dart.
It can help you integrate
third-party
libraries into your app.
Today, you'll install these
packages directly from git.
But soon, we'll help you search,
publish, install and
discover more third-party
Dart libraries via
pub.dartlang.org.
Thanks for watching, and
thanks for trying Dart.